>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION TO
TONIGHT'S NEWS, OPENING
MONOLOGUE, TOM FITTON AND
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GORKA, THERE IS SO
MUCH TO UNRAVEL HERE ON SO MANY
DIFFERENT LEVELS AND WHAT WE ARE
REALLY BEGINNING TO SEE IS THAT
MORE AND MORE OF THIS EVIDENCE
THAT THIS GOES BACK TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND EVEN THE PRESIDENT KNEW, THE
SUSAN RICE MEMO TO SELF IS VERY
REVEALING TO ME.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT IS SO TRANSPARENT, IT SIMPLY
TALKS TO THE ABILITY OR THE
INABILITY TO BE SUBTLE ABOUT A
COVER UP WHEN YOU ARE NO LONGER
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER.
LET ME JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT, I
WAS LISTENING TO YOUR MONOLOGUE
AND SOMETHING OCCURRED TO ME
LISTENING TO THE LAST SEGMENT.
ROBERT MUELLER WAS EMPOWERED TO
DO WHAT?
TO INVESTIGATE WHETHER THERE WAS
COLLUSION, WHATEVER THAT IS
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA.
THE ROD ROSENSTEIN PRESS
CONFERENCE STARTED WITH WHAT
STATEMENT, SEAN?
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE DESPITE
WHAT RUSSIA DID THAT THERE WAS
ANY EFFECT ON THE ELECTION.
THAT'S HOW HE STARTED.
SO WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
WHY ARE WE SPENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
THE FORMER KGB OFFICER, I GET
IT, BUT IF YOU START WITH THE
ASSERTION THAT NOTHING HAPPENED
TO CHANGE THE ELECTION, THEN WHY
DON'T YOU DISSOLVE THE WHOLE
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
>> Sean: THAT SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED A LONG TIME AGO, AND
YOU SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO PUT THE ABUSIVELY
BIASED TEAM TOGETHER.
LET ME READ YOU SOMETHING, THIS
WAS FROM THE DOJ ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM LAST FRIDAY WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY WENT OUT AND SAID WHEN
THEY SAID THE INDICTMENT
INCLUDES EIGHT CRIMINAL COUNTS
AND CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY, DEFRAUD
THE U.S., THAT DEFENDANTS
CONSPIRED TO DEFRAUD THE U.S.
WITH THE LAWFUL FUNCTIONS OF THE
FTC, THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE COMING U.S. DEPARTMENT
OF STATE IN ADMINISTRATING
FEDERAL DOMESTIC ACTIVITIES.
I WANT TO LOOK AT RUSSIA'S POINT
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS BRILLIANT
WHICH WAS THAT IF THEY WOULD
HAVE DONE IT IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE, THAT MEANS THAT HILLARY,
THAT MEANS FUSION, THAT MEANS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THAT MEANS
EVERYONE ELSE WITH THIS DAME
SAME STANDARDS, SO WHILE THEY
TALK BROADLY ABOUT IT AND MENTIN
TALK BROADLY ABOUT IT AND MENTII
TALK BROADLY ABOUT IT AND MENTIT
TALK BROADLY ABOUT IT AND MENTIN
THE PRESS RELEASE, THAT'S
NOT WHAT THEY WERE CHARGED WITH,
DO YOU SEE THAT THAT WAS DONE
PURPOSEFULLY?
>> I THINK IT WAS A
FUNDAMENTALLY DISHONEST DOCUMENT
DESIGNED TO DISTRACT FROM THE
FACT THAT THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
ARE COLLAPSING AND THE REASON
FOR BEING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS DISAPPEARING.
AND YOU HAVE IN MANY WAYS THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
RESPONDING APPROPRIATELY TO WHAT
THEY WERE DOING IN THIS
INDICTMENT BECAUSE THEY WERE
HAVING AN IN MATERIAL IMPACT ON
OUR PUBLIC POLICY PROCESS.
THEY SHOULD'VE BEEN TOLD TO STOP
MESSING AROUND, WHICH APPARENTLY
THEY WERE.
BUT THEY WERE NOT SPENDING A LOT
OF MONEY AND HAVING ZERO IMPACT.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND THEY WERE
MESSING AROUND SIGNIFICANTLY BY
TRYING TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP
THROUGH THIS DOSSIER LEAKING
THROUGH RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES TO THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
THAT WANDERED INTO THE OBAMA,
DOJ, AND FBI.
AND RATHER THAN RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY AND PROTECT
MR. TRUMP FROM THE SMEAR EVER BY
THE RUSSIANS THEY USE IT AS A
PRETEXT TO TARGET AND SPY ON HIM
AND HIS TEAM.
THAT IS THE SCANDAL IN THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF THE SCANDAL HOW
TO CHANGE WITH THE PRESS
RELEASE/INDICTMENT ON FRIDAY
THAT IS GOING TO GO NOWHERE.
>> Sean: THAT WAS A POLITICAL
DOCUMENT, THAT INDICTMENT,
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO ARREST ANY OF THE
PEOPLE, BUT YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN, THAT THERE IS RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, THERE WAS COMMAND
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC BROUGHT TO THE RUSSIANS
IN, DR. GORKA, THEY PAID THE
RUSSIANS TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS,
SHORT OF THE TROLLS, AND WHY
WANTED THE RUSSIANS THINK THAT
THEY COULD GET IN ON IT?
VLADIMIR PUTIN PUT HIS
OPERATIVES IN AMERICA AND GOT
OUR URANIUM, WHY WOULD THEY
THINK ANYTHING ELSE?
THERE ARE CATEGORIES FROM THE
COLD WAR, THE MICHAEL MOORE WAS
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UP
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UA
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS U
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UH
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UE
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UA
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UM
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UN
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS US
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UR
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UT
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UO
A USEFUL IDIOTS WHEN HE SHOWS UN
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP THAT IS
ORGANIZED BY THE RUSSIANS, BUT
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT USEFUL
IDIOTS WHEN IT COMES TO THE FISA
COURTS SURVEILLANCE AND THE
STEELE DOSSIER.
LET'S USE A PHRASE FROM THE
MILITARY, HILLARY CLINTON, HER
MULTIPLIERS FOR RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA THAT ATTACKED A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE DURING AN
ELECTION.
THEY WERE NOT UNWITTING, THEY
ACTUALLY PAID FOR IT.
MORE THAN $12 MILLION OF RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA PAID FOR AND FUNNELED
INTO AN ILLEGAL SURVEILLANCE
WARRANT AGAINST THE U.S. CITIZEN